Attacus atlas, einer der größten
Nachtfalter der Welt.
Phyllium giganteum, was aussieht wie
Blätter, sind Gespenstschrecken.
Dynastes hercules, zusammen mit dem
Riesenbockkäfer der größte seiner Art.
Eine kleine Auswahl aus
Adrian Kozakiewiczs Sammlung.
Der Züchter inszeniert seine Insekten
und Spinnen in Internetvideos
und begeistert damit Millionen Zuschauer.
Berührungsängste - Fehlanzeige.
Ich hatte schon immer Insekten zu Hause
gehabt. Ich hab immer Insekten gehalten,
Insekten gefangen von draußen,
mal gezüchtet. Das gehört dazu,
das gehört zu mir, dass ich Insekten habe
und halte, und das ist etwas Normales.
Weit mehr als eine halbe Million Menschen
folgen ihm allein auf Facebook.
Neben seinem Insektenhandel
verdient er mit
der Lizenzierung der viralen Videos Geld.
Zwischen 200 und 400 Euro
erhält er pro Clip. Dazu kommt oft noch
eine Gewinnbeteiligung.
Je skurriler der Content,
desto höher die Chance,
seine Videos an Agenturen zu verkaufen.
Die Bestseller sind seine Selfie-Videos.
Es fühlt sich normalerweise nicht
schlimm an. Außer es sind zum Beispiel
große Gespenst(er)schrecken, die
ziemlich große Krallen haben und sich
irgendwo zwischen - nicht zwischen
dem Auge,
aber neben dem Auge so reinkrallen.
Das ist eher unangenehm.
Und was auch sehr unangenehm war,
war schon die größte Schnecke der Welt,
die ich aufs [auf dem] Gesicht hatte,
ja, die war eher zu glitschig.
Drehplatz für die Videos ist eine
Einfamilienhaussiedlung
in der Nähe von Karlsruhe. In dem Keller
seiner Eltern herrschen 24 Grad Celsius.
So mögen es die Tiere am liebsten -
wie diese Goliathkäfer,
die bis zu elf Zentimeter lang werden
und in Afrika heimisch sind.
Ein anderes Highlight:
seine australischen Riesenschaben.
250 Euro ist ein Paar bei Sammlern wert.
Rund 50 Insekten- und Spinnenarten
besitzt Adrian Kozakiewicz. Die meisten
von ihnen sind Gottesanbeterinnen.
Es gibt Arten wie diese, die sich perfekt
den Blättern anpassen,
z.B. die imitieren tote Blätter. Es gibt
auch natürlich Arten,
die lebende Blätter imitieren oder
die Blüten imitieren.
Es gibt wirklich eine riesige Vielfalt
an Arten.
Das ist das sehr Spannende und
Faszinierende an Gottesanbeterinnen.
Adrian Kozakiewiczs Insekten sind
pflegeleicht. Während seine
fleischfressenden Gottesanbeterinnen
nur lebende Tiere wie Heuschrecken
oder Spinnen essen, bekommen die
Stabheuschrecken aus Madagaskar
alle drei Tage frische
Brombeerblätter serviert.
Insekten sind die größte Tierklasse
überhaupt. In den tropischen
Regenwäldern leben noch viele
unentdeckte Arten.
Drei- bis viermal jährlich geht der
gebürtige Pole auf Entdeckungstour
nach Südostasien, um neue
Tiere mitzubringen -
natürlich nur solche, die nicht unter
Artenschutz stehen. Exotische Insekten
als Ware und Haustier: Regelmäßig
beschweren sich Tierschützer bei ihm.
Viele Leute vermenschlichen auch das
zu sehr, die Insekten.
Die haben kein Bewusstsein, aber das
einzige, was sie empfinden,
ist Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit, die
Nährstoffe in den Futtertieren,
was die [die sie] fressen zum Beispiel.
Und das muss man einfach anbieten
und dann ist alles gut.
Der Erfolg in den sozialen Medien zieht
längst nicht nur Insektenfans an.
2017 lud ihn die italienische Marke
„Gucci“ samt Insekten
zu einem exklusiven Mode-Event nach
Florenz ein.
Besonders gut kommen diese
Dorngespenstschrecken bei seinen Fans an
- wegen des hohen Skurrilitäts-
und Ekelfaktors.
Mit jedem Video steigt auch die
Popularität von Insekten als Haustier.
Ich bekomme schon immer mehr Anfragen,
[das] merke ich schon auch jedes Jahr,
dass (es) immer mehr Leute interessiert
sind, Insekten zu halten,
anstatt vielleicht Reptilien zu halten.
Insekten und Wirbellose allgemein ist
[sind] eher was Neues, also neues Markt
[neu auf dem Markt].
Insekten: Für die einen Plagegeister,
beängstigend und eklig -
- für Adrian Kozakiewicz: die spannendsten
und schönsten Tiere der Welt.